well before covid there was already a
national shortage of dental hygienist
and then once the pandemic hit nearly
half of the hygienists either quit or
they retired eight news now anchor
Kirsten Joy spoke to a Las Vegas dentist
on what's being done to recruit more
hygienists I think it's a wonderful
profession for people to
OK teen years she
inch area her second in the Medical
District on Charleston Staffing these
locations has proved challenging we were
actively looking for a dental hygienist
for over two years before we filmed the
one my friends my dental friends here in
Las Vegas as well have been looking and
some still haven't gone after dental
hygienists she hired dental hygienist
Emily Wang who moved to Las Vegas from
California as a hygienist it's really
great that you can work alongside with
dentists and you can help diagnose
anything that you see within a patient
at American Dental Association poll
showed nearly 40 percent of dental
practices are trying to recruit
hygienists and of those 95 percent said
it's been difficult to hire someone in
the 20 largest U.S cities the poll found
that only half of hygienist positions
are reported as filled since covid
annual salaries for dental hygienists
have nearly doubled to an average of
ninety thousand dollars it is nice to be
advised but I feel like it is more of
appealing especially for new grads
nowadays and with our economy it's it's
great it's a great compensation for
Emily the career choice more about the
flexibility it offers with being a mom
as well for Dr meveson the higher salary
to get great talent like Emily is worth
every penny but the current downside
dental insurance has not increased the
reimbursements to help match that so
it's a it's a big issue for a lot of
dental professionals Across the Nation
because we're trying to accommodate the
higher salary without the
um reimbursement rates going up